cuatro horas de conversaciones pero
ningún terreno en común sobre la
seguridad en europa este fue el segundo
intento esta semana para disipar un
posible conflicto entre rusia y ucrania
el motivo de preocupación es la
acumulación masiva de tropas de moscú a
lo largo de su frontera pero rusia se
mantuvo firme y dijo que no podría haber
progreso hasta que eeuu y sus aliados
europeos descartaron la membresía de
kiev en la otan
es imperativo absoluto poner fin a la
política de puertas abiertas y
proporcionar a la federación rusa
garantías legales para que la otan no
avance hacia el este
eeuu rechazó el veto sobre ucrania o
cualquier otro país para unirse a la
otan
no cerraremos la puerta de golpe a la
política de puertas abiertas de la otan
hoy le dijimos directamente a los rusos
que si rusia sigue invadiendo granma
habrá costos y consecuencias
significativas
en diciembre rusia planteó una serie de
demandas con el objetivo de evitar que
la otan se expandiera más hacia el este
la alianza ha rechazado esas demandas
pero su secretario general jens
stoltenberg dijo que estaban dispuestos
a discutir sus envíos de armas a ucrania
agregó que aún era posible una solución
a la crisis por defensas una de nuestras
diferencias no serán fáciles de manejar
pero es una señal positiva que todos los
aliados de la otan y rusia se sentarán
alrededor de la misma mesa y se
involucrarán en temas sustantivos james
jones substance tópix se espera que en
las conversaciones con rusia y los
aliados de la otan continúen el jueves
en la sede de la organización para la
seguridad y la cooperación en europa
ubicada en viena